we responded to a call for service
reference a
vehicle collision involving a bicyclist
and a vehicle
unfortunately the bicyclist is deceased
on scene
the details of the call around the 2000
block of paradise
a bicyclist was northbound on paradise
and a nissan
sentra 2011 model was heading
southbound on paradise and the vehicle
was unable to maintain the travel lane
lost control end up going into the
oncoming traffic hitting the bicyclist
and unfortunately bicyclists did not
survive this collision
there is no signs of impairment um at
this time
and uh the details the bicyclist is
around the age of 50
in his 50s appears to be a white male
adult
and the uh at fault driver is hispanic
male younger adult in his early 20s
what kind of charges are you guys
looking at for something like this
um right now the charges are still going
to be pending until we get to complete
investigation of what occurred so right
now there are no charges being filed
and that will come at a later date and
we'll give you guys a um a briefing on
that
as far as what could uh what charges
could be uh forthcoming
the drivers stayed on scene but yes the
driver did stay on scene
um and we have them here as well
good thing else we got it whatever you
need thank you awesome all right you
guys thank you